en el último vídeo teníamos una masa que
en realidad era este bloque de hielo y
que tenía
bueno era una masa de 10 kilogramos
sobre un plano inclinado en un ángulo de
30 grados verdad y para poder deducir
que le podría pasar a este bloque
descompusimos la fuerza de gravedad
sobre que actúa sobre este bloque en sus
componentes que son paralelas y
perpendicular a la superficie del plano
verdad que de hecho aquí está la fuerza
de gravedad desde esta línea verde y la
línea roja es la la la componente
perpendicular a la superficie y la
amarilla bueno cualquiera de estas dos
es es exactamente igual es la componente
paralela a la superficie muy bien
entonces para la perpendicular teníamos
que este vector tenía una magnitud de 49
x raíz de 3 newtons y que iba en
dirección hacia dentro del plano y no
y no veíamos que el bloque acelerará
hacia abajo verdad porque justamente
nuestro plano o nuestra rampa lo
sostiene y entonces podríamos decir que
existe una fuerza que contrarresta
justamente la
la componente perpendicular y esa es la
fuerza normal de este que imprime el
plano sobre nuestro bloque y es opuesta
por supuesto a la componente
perpendicular de la gravedad verdad pues
pues de esta forma si se balancean sin
embargo lo que es la componente paralela
de la fuerza de gravedad no tenía
problemas ahí habíamos supuesto que
tenía teníamos una fuerza de 49 newtons
y decíamos que si no había alguna otra
fuerza entonces acelera verdad y vimos
cuál era su aceleración simplemente
calculamos la
la fuerza dividida entre la masa y eso
nos daba la aceleración ahora digamos
que eso no va a ocurrir vamos a suponer
ahora que nuestro bloque es estacionario
no se podríamos pensar a lo mejor que la
rampa y que la también además de la
rampa nuestro bloque de hielo no no son
de hielo ahora si no no se podríamos
pensar que son de madera y si son de
madera vamos a pensar entonces que este
bloque ahora es estacionario es decir ya
no se mueve entonces cuál sería
necesariamente este caso aunque entonces
si no se mueve entonces tenemos que debe
existir alguna fuerza y déjenme y
déjenme incluso quitar esto de aquí
déjenme déjenme borrar esto porque
justamente vamos a hablar al respecto de
la fricción pero bueno si no existe
digamos si no existe movimiento de este
bloque lo que sí debe existir es alguna
fuerza que vaya en esta dirección alguna
fuerza que vaya en esta dirección pero
que contrarreste justamente la fuerza
que va en en dirección paralela o la
componente paralela de la fuerza de
gravedad verdad entonces cuál es esta
fuerza de aquí la experiencia nos dice
que si hay una diferencia entre digamos
si tenemos un bloque y una y un plano de
hielo a que si estos son de madera por
ejemplo si los dos fueran de hielo sería
esto más resbaloso y eso significa que
hay menos fricción o en nuestro caso no
había fricción sin embargo si ahora
tenemos que están hechos ambos de madera
eso quiere decir que
es hay más fricción está aquí ya no se
mueve entonces esta fuerza de aquí esta
fuerza que contrarresta la componente
paralela es la fuerza de fricción verdad
entonces aquí estamos suponiendo que
nuestro bloque es estacionario
estacionario y que la fuerza de fricción
es de 49 newtons verdad porque
justamente contrarresta esto es de 49
newtons y vamos a escribir que va hacia
arriba d
la
de la rampa ok de la rampa muy bien
entonces la fuerza de fricción va en
esta dirección entonces la pregunta es
ahí hay una hay esta fuerza de fricción
va en contra de la aceleración potencial
si no tuviéramos fricción verdad la
aceleración que existiría si no
tuviéramos fricción entonces la pregunta
más interesante es cuánto hay que
empujar para que esto empiece a
descender verdad puede ser que a lo
mejor si empujamos un poco no descienda
sin embargo cuál cuánto hay que empujar
para que empieza a descender muy bien
entonces eso digamos una pregunta
interesante y vamos a suponer para
nuestro caso que si uno aplica una
fuerza extra
digamos que que una vez que uno le
imprima una fuerza de un newton entonces
este bloque empieza a descender empieza
a descender en esta dirección
ok entonces lo interesante aquí es es
que todo esto está basado
en los materiales de contacto y ahorita
vamos a ver en qué sentido vamos a ver
por ejemplo digamos que la fuerza a
partir de la cual empieza a descender
entonces tenemos aquí 49 newtons y un
newton vamos a no sea llamarle la fuerza
no sé qué que provoca movimiento muy
bien y va en la dirección paralela a la
superficie muy bien entonces esta fuerza
es de 50 newtons y es de 50 minutos
justamente porque teníamos 49 por
efectos de la gravedad por la componente
paralela a la superficie de la gravedad
más un newton que le imprimimos para que
comience apenas a moverse
entonces la magnitud de este vector de
este vector desde esta fuerza es
justamente 50 newtons ok entonces si
nosotros dividimos
en realidad está esta fuerza mínima que
necesitamos depende de los materiales en
los que estemos hablando verdades es la
fuerza que necesitamos para superar
digamos la fricción ok
aunque entonces sí si nosotros dividimos
ahora entre la fuerza del más bien la
magnitud de la fuerza normal ok
ahí digamos estamos comparando como es
esta fuerza que empieza a provocar el
movimiento con la fuerza que existe
entre el contacto de estas dos
superficies digamos de aquí entonces si
nosotros dividimos entre la fuerza que
es eran 49 raíz de 3 newtons entonces
este coeficiente a es a lo más bien a
este número es a lo que le voy a llamar
el coeficiente de fricción estática
ok este es el coeficiente
estática ok y lo que está haciendo el
coeficiente de fricción estática es más
o menos
me está diciendo es más o menos la
fuerza de fricción dividido entre entre
la fuerza normal verdad y podría uno
interpretarlo como que es la mayor
fricción posible que se le puede aplicar
por el rozamiento digamos entre estos
dos cuerpos verdad entre dos cosas
entonces esto por supuesto es cuando es
estacionario ya después veremos qué pasa
en otros casos y este y este coeficiente
suele ser una suele ser bueno suele ser
muy bueno para muchos materiales ok en
digamos para lo que digamos para los
cuerpos como un este un bloque y una
rampa ok entonces esto suele ser
bastante bueno y para este caso en
particular vamos a ver cómo se calcula
entonces para este caso particular
tenemos 50 tendríamos
teníamos ahí 50 dividido entre 40 que
multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de 3
verdad ok
entonces vamos a ver cuánto es esto y
esto nos da 0.72 116 entonces vamos a
escribir que esto es 0.72 vamos a
dejarlo ahí muy bien entonces esto como
ya habíamos dicho es más o menos la
mayor fricción posible que se le puede
aplicar y en otros vídeos veremos cuál
es la diferencia cuando se están
moviendo por ejemplo este cuerpo
por ejemplo en este caso que es
estacionario pueden ser parecidas en la
mayoría de los casos pero a veces si
pueden diferir bastante según el
material de lo que estén hechos estos
dos cuerpos pero bueno te dejo con eso
para que lo pienses y en los próximos
vídeos examinaremos más el coeficiente
de fricción para resolver más
otro tipo de problemas